well federal agents working to secure
our borders are not the only ones in
danger from an increasingly extreme
left-wing two years ago a maniac tried
to murder Republicans practicing for
congressional baseball game now
congressman Matt Gaetz of Florida says
he has been receiving threatening
voicemails at his office here's one of
them date you pathetic pieces you know
that I could blow your head clean off
your shoulders from over a mile away
watch your back you pathetic little
pieces you got your head so far up from
I could still pick it off your shoulders
you date I'm coming after you so that's
about as clear-cut as it could be those
are threats they're a crime
here's the remarkable part according to
gates the FBI has already identified the
person you just heard the person who
threatened him but a federal prosecutor
has decided not to bring charges
congressman Matt gates afford existing
permit am i misstating any of that no I
received word late last week that the US
Attorney's office where this individual
lived had reviewed the information and
had deemed these messages and I'm
quoting directly a non threat it's
obviously a crime a federal crime to
make these types of threats against any
federal official this year were not this
Congress I should say we're on record
for 10,000 threats against members of
Congress and I condemn them whether
they're against Republicans Democrats
liberals conservatives you know this is
just no way to operate within our
country and I just wonder like is it the
fact that I've been a critic of some of
the senior officials at the FBI that
maybe leads to different treatment for
the people who threaten me as opposed to
the people who actually get arrested who
have threatened Eric's wall well you
know Ilhan Omar Rashida to leave those
people actually get arrested whereas
when people threaten conservatives I I
hope there's not a double standard but I
mean you heard the messages and there
were even other messages where they
threatened my family tucker who is this
prosecutor who
told you that that was that what we just
listened to clearly a threat of violence
was somehow not a threat it was the US
Attorney for the Northern District of
California that their office made the
determination that this was a closed
matter that they would bring no charges
and that we're just supposed to deal
with that and it's really you know
people on the left want to talk about
threats to our democracy our democracy
is served when our representatives have
fidelity to the Constitution and to our
constituents when you have to have
fidelity to some concern that someone's
going to you know kill you or kill your
family or harm you at a public event it
erodes the representation that every
member of Congress should be able to
provide their district regardless of
their viewpoint that's I mean this is
lunatic have you received any support
from your Democratic colleagues in this
look it's been a crazy few weeks for me
I mean just a few weeks ago I had a
member of an Tifa a stated member of an
tyfa assaulting me at a town hall
meeting and get arrested one fantastic
democratic congresswoman Stephanie
Murphy of Florida condemned it she was
the only one since then a Pete Budaj
edge staff member said that people
should throw urine on me and then I
received these threatening messages and
no federal prosecutors so far seem to be
interested in in those cases and you
know just it's this isn't this is no way
to get together and solve the problems
we have to solve for the country it's no
way to govern and I wish there would be
more bipartisan support for non-violence
yes throw urine on you what a judge
should be ashamed though of course he
never will be congressman great to see
you tonight thank you thank you